EXAMINE THIS NIGHTMARE SCENARIO.
THE SACRIFICE OF A SMALL CHILD
ON THE ALTER OF SOCIALIZED
MEDICINE.
FIRST, THE NEW COUNTER CULTURE,
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
ENTERTAINMENT ELITES ARE IN
FREAK-OUT MODE.
WHY?
ONE OF THEIR MEGASTARS, KANYE
WEST, ANNOUNCED THAT HE'S
THINKING FOR HIMSELF.
FELT LIKE A CULTURAL EARTHQUAKE
OVER THE WEEKEND WHEN WEST
TWEETED THAT HE LIKED THE WAY A
CONSERVATIVE BLACK ACTIVIST
THOUGHT.
HE FOLLOWED IT UP WITH PRO TRUMP
TWEETS THAT HAS THE INTERNET
EXPLODING.
HE DECLARED HIS LOVE FOR TRUMP
AND EX-STOLED THE DRAGON ENERGY
THEY SHARE.
WHAT IS THAT?
HE REFUSED TO LET THE MOB SHAKE
HIS LOVE FOR THE PRESIDENT.
NOW LOOK, THIS ISN'T ABOUT
CELEBRATING ONE SUPERSTAR'S
ENDORSEMENT OF DONALD TRUMP.
WHAT I'M GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT IS SHINING A LIGHT ON THE
MORE INTOLLERANT CROWD OUT
THERE.
YOU KNOW, THE PEOPLE THAT CLAIM
THAT THEY HAVE A MONOPOLY ON
TOLERANCE AND INCLUSION?
THINK ABOUT THIS.
OTHER THAN ACADEMIA, THERE'S FEW
INDUSTRIES THAT AMERICA, THE
AMERICAN LEFT DOMINATES LIKE IT
DOES ENTERTAINMENT.
FOR KANYE'S SIN OF SPEAKING HIS
MIND, MUSICAL ICONS LIKE NICKI
MINAJ AND DRAKE AND RIHANNA
UNFOLLOWED HIM ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
WHAT A PUNISHMENT.
THE REACTION FROM THE LEFT WAS
JUST AS PRONOUNCED.
>> DIFFERENT CELEBRITY
>> DIFFERENT CELEBRIIE
>> DIFFERENT CELEBRIIES
DESPERATE FOR ATTENTION.
>> NOW HIS WIFE IS TWEETING BACK
AT PEOPLE SAYING DON'T BE TOO
HARD ON MY HUSBAND.
DON'T MAKE IT SEEM LIKE HE'S
GOING THROUGH A MENTAL BREAK
DOWN, WHICH WE KNOW HE'S HAD.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
I THINK KANYE WEST JUST REALIZED
HE'S TOO RICH TO NOT BE
REPUBLICAN.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
>> WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
INDEPENDENT THOUGHTS AND I
INDEPENDENTLY THINK THAT KANYE
HAS LOST HIS MIND.
>> IS STEPHEN STILL?
CHARACTER?
I FORGET.
ORIGINAL THOUGHT WILL NOT BE
TOLERATED.
ANYONE THAT BREAKS FROM THE BORG
MINDSET MUST BE SHUNNED OR
BULLIED BACK INTO THE FOLD.
KANYE SHARED A TEXT EXCHANGE
WITH JOHN LEGEND.
LOVE HIS MUSIC.
BUT THIS ILLUSTRATES THE POINTS.
JOHN LEGEND SAID YOU'RE WAY TOO
POWERFUL TO ENDORSE WHAT HE IS
AND WHAT HE STANDS FOR.
SO MANY PEOPLE THAT LOVE YOU
FEEL BETRAYED RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THE HARM THAT TRUMP'S
POLICIES CAUSE.
ESPECIALLY FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR.
DON'T LET THIS BE PART OF YOUR
LEGACY.
KANYE WEST WASN'T IMPRESSED.
HE SAID I LOVE YOU, JOHN, BUT
BRINGING UP MY FANS AND MY
LEGACY IS A TACTIC BASED ON FEAR
USED TO MANIPULATE MY FREE
THOUGHT.
HE'S RIGHT.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M SAYING THAT
ON MY SHOW, KANYE WEST IS RIGHT.
HE'S RIGHT ABOUT THIS.
ANYONE THAT DARES TO QUESTION
THE IDEALOGICAL ORTHODOXSY OF
THE LEFT, PARTICULARLY A BLACK
ARTIST, MUST BE BROUGHT BACK
INTO LINE.
NOW, LET'S TALK TURKEY HERE.
WHERE KANYE WEST IS PUNKING THE
ELITES OR WHETHER HE'S SINCERELY
EXPRESSING A BELIEF AND THE
PRESIDENT IS IMMATERIAL.
HE'S OPENED THE DOOR OF THE
GLARING HYPOCRISY OF THE LEFT.
THEY CLAIM TO DEFEND MINORITY
RIGHTS UNTIL A MINORITY
DISAGREES WITH THEM.
THEY CLAIM TO BE FOR DIVERSITY
UNTIL A TRULY DIVERSE VIEWPOINT
IS HEARD.
WHAT WEST MIGHT HAVE UNWITTINGLY
DONE IS MADE IT A LITTLE EASIER
FOR OTHERS TO STAND UP AGAINST
THIS HERD MENTALITY.
HE DID RECEIVE SOME SUPPORT FOR
HIS INDEPENDENCE.
CHANCE, THE RAPPER, HARDLY A
CONSERVATIVE VOICE, TWEETED
THIS.
BLACK PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO BE
DEMOCRATS.
CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
SO SCANDALOUS.
I DON'T THINK THAT KANYE WEST IS
THE NEW MLK.
ALL RIGHT?
I HAVE VIVID MEMORIES OF HIM AT
SOME TELEVISED FUND RAISER IN
THE WAKE OF HURRICANE.
>> GEORGE BUSH DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT BLACK PEOPLE.
>> THAT WASN'T NICE.
I CAN REMEMBER WHEN HE RUDELY
RUSHED THE STAGE TO TRY TO TAKE
A MUSIC AWARD FROM TAYLOR SWIFT.
THAT ALSO WASN'T NIGHT.
15 YEARS AGO, YES, I CAN HARDLY
BELIEVE IT, I WROTE A BOOK
CALLED "SHUT UP AND SING" WAS A
CRITIQUE OF THE POLITICAL
ACTIVISM OF THESE PEOPLE LIKE
THE DIXIE CHICKS AND JACKSON
BROWN AND ON AND ON.
THE UPSHOT IS, WE PAY THEM TO
ENTERTAIN.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE CAPTIVE TO
THEIR POLITICAL PONDERING.
SOMEONE WHO FOR SOME UN-GODLY
REASON DOES GET PAID TO
PONTIFICATE ON POLITICS, HER
NAME IS MISS ANNA NAVARRO
TWEETED AT ME.
HAS SHE TOLD KANYE TO SHUT UP
AND SING YET OR DOES THAT ONLY
APPLY TO ANTI-TRUMP BLACK
CELEBRITIES?
I'LL MAKE IT CLEAR TO YOU, ANNA,
IT APPLIES TO ANYONE PEDALLING
POLITICAL NONSENSE WHILE LACKING
THE CREDENTIALS OR EXPERIENCE TO
DO SO, ANA.
I'M NOT ABOUT TO CHEER ON KANYE
WEST BECAUSE HE SAID SOMETHING
NICE ABOUT TRUMP.
THE POLITICAL MUSINGS OF
UNINFIRMED CELEBRITIES IS NOT
INTERESTING TO ME AT ALL.
WHAT IS INTERESTING, THE OVERTHE
TOP REACTION TO A BIG STAR
SAYING SOMETHING TRULY COUNTER
CULTURAL TODAY.
THAT'S OF GREAT INTEREST TO ME.
WASHING THE LEFT ATTACK HIM FOR
DARING TO BREAK RANKS WITH THEM.
EVEN IN THE VAGUEST OF TERMS
TALKING ABOUT LOVE AND LOVING
PEOPLE THAT IS TRULY REVEALING.
WHAT KANYE WEST SAYS OR DOES IN
THE DAYS AHEAD IS LESS IMPORTANT
THAN THE CONVERSATION HE
STARTED.
AND WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT
A BAD BOY LIKE KIM KARDSHIAN'S
HUSBAND COULD BE THE CATALYST
FOR AN HONEST DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE COOERS CONFORMITY OF THOUGHT